hi this is presh talaker let's discuss
why group texts are annoying from a
mathematical perspective
imagine you want to invite three friends
for dinner
you'll need to communicate the details
to each person in the group
you could send individual texts in which
case you would send a text to each
person and each person would reply to
you
this is a total of six text messages
sent within the group
an alternate way you could organize the
dinner is by sending a group text
in this case your message would go to
each person in the group and then the
first person to reply would reply to
each person in the group
the next person would then reply to each
person and the last person would then
reply to each person
so since everyone's sending a message to
each person that's 12 messages and this
is why group texts are annoying because
they're more taxed to communicate the
same information
in general in general we can imagine
inviting n friends we can index this as
a set of 0 to n friends
if you were to organize it by individual
text then we can count the number of
texts person 0 would send text to each
person in the group
and each of those people would respond
with the message back to zero
this is a total of two n texts that are
sent within the group
if you organize it as a group text
then person 0 would send group text
which goes to each person in the group
the first person would reply to each
person in the group
and so on so that each person in the
group is replying
since there are n plus one people
sending n messages
that means there are total of n squared
plus n text that are sent within the
group
we can graph out how much more messages
are needed for the group text
if you send individual text you would
need 6 8 10 or 12
messages between three to six friends
the extra number of texts required for
group text are 6 for three twelve for
four twenty four five and whopping
thirty extra text if you have a group of
six
so if group text
needs so many more text messages why do
people use it
one answer is game theory
when you use individual text it requires
one person being the initiator to send
out those initial end messages
in a group text that one person would
just send out one group message
the other advantage is the group text
gives you group common knowledge
in general the groups are better off if
someone organizes the event but no one
wants to do that extra work
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can
get my books on amazon